et les énergies tout un programme au
coeur de la campagne présidentielle le
pouvoir d'achat aussi à l'heure où
l'inflation monte en flèche d'après
l'insee la hausse des prix pourrait
atteindre 3 5% d'ici à cet été en
attendant les candidats y vont de leurs
propositions bien souvent axées sur la
hausse des salaires alors quelles
grandes tendances s'affrontent dans
cette campagne qui comprend mieux les
attentes des français sur leur pouvoir
d'achat on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir seller
l'élite aux échos
bonsoir jacques merci d'être avec nous
alors est ce que vous diriez sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat qu'elle est
importante voire décisif dans cette
campagne présidentielle ah oui elle sera
très certainement très important avec la
question du pouvoir d'achat il ya
derrière évidemment le problème de
l'inflation alors on sait que
l'inflation augmente extrêmement vite
aux etats-unis +2 7% +2 5% en allemagne
on est quand même à plus de 3% en france
peut-être même 3 25% après ce qu annonce
l'insee et ça aura évidemment des
conséquences sur le pouvoir d'achat
d'autant plus que le pouvoir d'achat et
ça on le sait il est en berne depuis
plusieurs années voire même des
décennies en france et donc il y aura un
véritable problème du pouvoir d'achat et
de l'inflation dont sept dans cette
élection est à voir à quoi est due cette
inflation alors l'inflation est en fait
due à trois facteurs tout d'abord il y à
la hausse de l'ensemble des matières
premières si vous voulez matières
premières agricoles les métaux le
pétrole
bref toutes les matières premières
augmente très fortement
ses billets à la sortie de la crise de
l'aco vie mais on voit quand même que
cette augmentation
elle est particulièrement forte pour
certains produire on a dépassé les plus
hauts que l'on avait connu en 2008 2009
ça c'est un premier point deuxième point
mais quand même et là avec le discours
d' emmanuel macron on est en plein dans
le sujet
les états ont lancé des grands
programmes d'investissement alors qu'il
s'agisse de refaire des infrastructures
comme en allemagne qu'il s'agisse de
préparer la transition énergétique comme
en france avec le développement
justement de l'industrie nucléaire bref
tout cela crée un contexte qui est
désormais un contexte clairement
inflationnistes et puis il ya une
troisième
disons il ya un troisième facteur qui
lui est beaucoup plus spécifique à la
france c'est le fait que en réalité
pendant la crise de l'aco vie il ya eu
une baisse de la productivité or qui dit
baisse de la productivité dit
nécessairement hausse des coûts alors on
peut dire bon d'accord la productivité
va repartir de l'avant oui mais il
faudra plusieurs trimestres voire
plusieurs semestre pour que l'on arrive
à nouveau à un niveau équivalent à celui
de 2010 9,7 inflation elle arrive quand
même au plus mauvais moment pour le
gouvernement
oui ah oui tout à fait on est en pleine
période électorale on comprend on
comprend effectivement est d'autant plus
qu'il ya plusieurs problèmes alors tout
d'abord vous avez un problème c'est que
la hausse des prix elle n'est pas
ressentie de la même manière dans les
différentes catégories de la population
les disons les plus pauvres les trois
premiers déciles il ressent une
inflation qui est supérieure à la
moyenne
les plus riches les deux ou trois
premiers dernier décile ils ressentent
une inflation qui est nettement
inférieur à la moyenne on le voit
d'ailleurs sur le graphique qui
s'affiche à l'écran et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire comme le smic en particulier
il est calculé par rapport à la moyenne
ressenti de l'inflation eh bien ça veut
dire que les trois premiers déciles ils
perdent régulièrement 2 grosso modo 1998
à 2015 sur ce tableau ils perdent
régulièrement du pouvoir d'achat alors
ça ça premier problème deuxième problème
où se situe justement cette inflation
cette hausse des prix ne se situent
essentiellement sur des produits qui
sont tout à fait cruciaux pour les
budgets des classes moyennes et si vous
voulez des des gens les plus pauvres
c'est quoi c'est le transport le
carburant pour le transport pour le
chauffage aussi mais c'est aussi les
produits alimentaires donc ça ça fait un
deuxième problème est le troisième
problème est bien c'est que globalement
le pouvoir d'achat de certaines
catégories de la population je pense par
exemple aux enseignants je pense au
personnel un fil mais bon pour prendre
des cas vraiment archétypique qui sont
le plus connu dans l'opinion et bien
dans ces catégories en réalité le
pouvoir d'achat a perdu depuis une
vingtaine d'années des montants
considérables donc c'est la combinaison
de ces trois facteurs qui rend cette
espèce de démarrage de l'inflation
actuelle qui le rend tout à fait
explosif pour la question du pouvoir
d'achat la question c'est comment
réagissent les candidats à commencer par
le presque on va l'appeler comme ça le
presque candidat emmanuel macron alors
le presque candidat emmanuel macron et
bien ils fument analyse que bourdeau
cette inflation va être une inflation
transitoire qui ne durera que quelques
mois ce en quoi je pense qu'ils se
trompent et donc qu'est ce qui lie bas
il suffit de donner des prix la fameuse
prime dite anti inflation ou alors il
suffit de bloquer quelques prix en
sachant qu'on ne pourra pas maintenir ce
blocage très longtemps oui mais qu'est
ce qui va se passer si justement cette
inflation perdure et c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué avec ce contexte
d'investissements qui est en train de se
mettre en place dans l'ensemble des pays
d'europe d'ailleurs pas pas simplement
qu'en france est bien là il dit bon le
retour à l'emploi ça va d'une certaine
manière permettre aux gens de gagner
plus et donc ça va leur permettre
d'absorber ce choc d'inflation sauf que
ce retour à l'emploi actuellement ces
six cent mille personnes sur
6,5 millions de demandes d'emploi moins
de 10% donc on voit bien que là il ya un
véritable problème qui n'est pas couvert
par le discours où là je dirais la
programmatique du gouvernement et du
président et pour les autres candidats
alors pour les autres candidats c'est
très intéressant parce qu'on voit qu'il
ya en fait deux philosophies qui
s'opposent complètement alors je prends
d'abord les gens qui ont font fait à peu
près la même analyse qu emmanuel macron
même s'ils ne le disent pas madame
valérie pécresse monsieur eric zemmour
qu'est ce qui lie les 10 des primes
exactement ce que j'ai emmanuel macron
et puis disent oui on va augmenter le
salaire net en supprimant les charges
patronales sauf que qu'est ce que c'est
que les charges
c'est des cotisations en réalité qu'ils
ont pas payés par le salarié qui sont
payés par le patron qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ces cotisations elles servent
à alimenter le système social français
autrement dit si
vous voulez retirer de la fiche de paie
c'est très bien pour le salarié mais ça
voudra dire qu'il faudra lui reprendre
cet argent que ce soit par l'impôt ou
par d'autres moyens d'un autre côté donc
on voit bien là qu'il y à un véritable
problème structurel est en réalité qu
est-ce que ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que pour ces deux candidats
ils ont essentiellement dans la ligne de
mire la question de la compétitivité
française ce qui n'est pas faux mais il
raisonne comme si nous devions rester ad
vitam aeternam dans le cadre de l'euro
l'élection qui se jouera donc bel et
bien sur cette question du pouvoir
d'achat oui et c'est ça se voit aussi
avec les autres candidats si vous voulez
alors on a d'autres candidats comme par
exemple marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon
qui d'une certaine manière on peut être
pris plus conscience du phénomène
inflationniste qui se passe et là on le
voit très bien ils veulent à la fois des
quelques primes ils veulent surtout des
hausses pérenne des salaires nous avons
aussi fabien roussel le candidat du pcr
qui dit à peu de choses près la même
chose et puis nous avons anne hidalgo
qui avait promis rappelez-vous ce
doublement du salaire des enseignants en
un mandat et on ne sait même pas s'il
est doublement net c'est un fin c'est un
doublement salaires réels ou où ce sera
mangée par l'inflation bref il ya des
cons dit quand ces fouilles 1 et il y
aura quand même d'autres sujets qui vont
peser sur cette campagne jacques oui oui
il y aura certainement d'autres sujets
mais il faut comprendre une chose c'est
que la question du pouvoir d'achat et la
question de l'inflation c'est au coeur
actuellement des préoccupations des
français c'est très intéressant on voit
par exemple que dans les derniers
sondages
la question de l'immigration la question
de la sécurité ont reculé par rapport à
la question justement du pouvoir d'achat
et de l'inflation et donc même si ça ne
sera pas la seule question dont va dont
on va débattre dans cette campagne c'est
évident ça sera une question absolument
tu râles dans les débats et tout
candidat qui l'oublieraient risques
créés justement de l'oublier à ses
propres dépens merci beaucoup jacques
pour cette mise en garde et à la semaine
prochaine